We're asked to first find
the focus and directrix
of the parabola by
moving the orange point
and line to their
correct positions,
then use that
information to find
the equation of the parabola.
So just as a little
bit of review,
a parabola is a
conic section that
is formed from all
of the points that
are equidistant to
some point that we call
the focus and some line that
we called the directrix.
And what we have right
over here-- what it does
is, as we move
along the parabola,
as we move our cursor
along the parabola
right over here, it looks
at the distance to where
the current dot is
and then it tries
to plot that same distance to
some theoretical directrix.
And that's where
that line drops down.
And you can clearly
see right now
that this isn't working out,
that this is not equidistant.
So the first thing that I like
to do when I try to figure out
where the focus is
is that the parabola
is going to be symmetric
around the focus,
or at least around the vertical
line that the focus is on,
I should say.
And so the focus is going to
sit right above the vertex.
So that's the first thing to do.
And so let me keep
manipulating it.
So if I look below
down there-- and it's
hard to do that because
when I move the cursor then
that green thing
disappears-- but if you look
at that vertical green line,
that shouldn't be moving--
the bottom of it shouldn't
be moving up and down.
It should be equidistant
to a flat line.
So let me keep playing with it.
It looks like that
might be an improvement.
Let me see.
So this actually
looks pretty good.
Notice the bottom--
oops-- notice
the bottom of the
vertical green line
is not moving in the
vertical direction.
It's just moving in the
horizontal direction.
So if I move my directrix up
there, that should work out.
So let me move it up there.
And there you have it.
Notice now my parabola--
these green lines
show the distance to the
focus and the distance
to the directrix, and notice
that they are always the same.
So it looks like I got the right
focus and the right directrix
now.
So I got the right focus
and the right directrix.
And the focus is 1/4
comma negative 3/8.
And the directrix is
y equals negative 5/8.
So now let's try to
use that information
to actually find the equation
of the parabola in this form
right over here.
And this is going to involve a
little bit of algebra for us.
So actually let me
copy and paste this.
So I'm going to
copy and paste this
so that we know what
we need, and let
me open my little
scratch pad up.
All right.
So this is our
information, and we
need to figure out the
equation of the parabola.
So just as a little bit of
review, we have the point.
So let's say this is our point.
This is our focus-- is the
point 1/4 comma negative 3/8.
And then we have the directrix
at y equals negative 5/8.
So the directrix looks
something like this.
That is y is equal
to negative 5/8.
And then we have our parabola.
And it looks
something like this.
It's equidistant to
the 2, so our parabola
looks something like that.
And the parabola, the x's and
y's that satisfy this equation
are all of the x's
and y's that are
equidistant to these two things.
So let's call that x comma y.
So let's find an equation for
all of the x's and y's that
are equidistant to this
point and to this line
right over here.
So, first, let's think about
the distance between this focus
and this x, y right over here.
Well, that distance just comes
straight out of the distance
formula, which comes straight
out of the Pythagorean theorem.
It's going to be x
minus 1/4 squared
plus y minus
negative 3/8 squared.
So that's going to be
y plus 3/8 squared.
So this is our distance squared.
We could take the square root if
we-- Why don't we just do that?
So let me just take
the square root.
So this is the distance between
any point on the parabola x, y
and the focus.
And the distance between that
same point and the directrix--
well, that's just going to
be a straight, vertical line.
So that's just going
to be our change in y.
So this is going to be equal
to y minus negative 5/8,
which is the same
thing as y plus 5/8.
And just to make sure that
this is always positive,
let's square it and then
take the square root.
Now, to simplify
this, we could square
both sides of this equation.
And we get x minus
1/4 squared plus y--
and actually let
me expand this out.
This will be useful
for us in a second,
so let me expand this out.
So this is going to be y
squared plus-- let's see,
2 times 3/8 is 3/4-- so
plus 3/4y plus 9/64 is
equal to this thing squared,
which is just y-- well, let me
actually expand
that out as well.
So that's y squared plus 2
times 5/8 is going to be 5/4.
5/4y plus 25 over 64.
Now, let me see if
I can simplify it.
I have a y squared
on both sides,
so I can cancel those terms out.
So y squared, y squared.
Let me subtract 3/4y
from both sides.
And let me subtract
9/64 from both sides.
Minus 9/64.
Actually, we had a
little more space.
So that's going to be gone
and that's going to be gone.
Our left hand side is
just going to simplify
to x minus 1/4 squared.
And that's going to be
equal to-- let's see.
5/4 minus 3/4 is 2/4, which
is the same thing as 1/2y.
And then 25/64
minus 9/64 is 16/64,
which is just the
same thing as 1/4.
So it's going to
be plus 1/4 there.
Now, we're almost got
where we need to go.
We have this x
minus 1/4 squared.
We just need to get a
coefficient out here and write
this in terms of
y minus something.
So what we can do
right over here
is we can factor out a 1/2.
So let's do that.
So this is going to be
x minus 1/4 squared is
equal to-- factoring out a
1/2, it's 1/2 times y plus 1/2.
And now, in order to put it in
the form that they care about,
they just have y minus
something right over here
and then something times
x minus something squared.
So we need to get this 1/2
or get this coefficient
on the other side.
The easiest way I
know how to do that
is to multiply both sides by 2.
So you multiply both sides by 2.
That cancels.
And if we really want
to put it in the form
that they care about,
we can swap the sides.
Instead of writing
y plus 1/2, we
can write that as y
minus negative 1/2.
That's the same
thing as y plus 1/2--
I'm going to do it
in the same form
that they want-- is equal to
2 times x minus 1/4 squared.
So let me see.
Did I do that right?
Yep.
y minus negative 1/2 is the
same thing as y plus 1/2
is equal to 2 times
x minus 1/4 squared.
So let me see if we got
that actually right.
So let's see.
It's negative 1/2 here,
positive 2, and then 1/4.
So we have it is negative
1/2, positive 2, and then 1/4.
Let's see if we got it right.
And we did.